parce que c'est l'heure de l'invité de
paris direct
et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
andreï kourkov bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes écrivain
ukrainien né en russie au tour auteur du
célèbre pingouins traduit dans le monde
entier votre dernier roman les abbayes
grise est sorti il ya quelques semaines
chez liana levi vous étiez venu nous le
présenter sur ce plateau on était tout
début février j'ai revu l'entretien nous
avions fait ensemble et je ne saurais
pas dire si à l'époque vous pensiez on
était le 3 février je crois que la
guerre allait arriver en ukraine trois
semaines plus tard vous nous aviez dit
en tout cas qu'une partie des ukrainiens
à l'époque se préparer à cette
éventualité
est ce que la réalité de ce que vous
vivez depuis deux mois a balayé la
sidération oui c'est une vie
complètement différente maintenant mais
moi oui je n'étais pas sûr que la guerre
va commencer je pensais que on va avoir
une installation à d'une basse à nouveau
mais pas la guerre totale par les
bombardements de grandes villes comme
qu'ils aient fini de salvi fait tout ça
est maintenant au c c'est horrible à
dire on s'adapte à avis pendant la
guerre et à la guerre parce que
maintenant il n'ya pas des dix régions
d'ukraine qui est vraiment de son
sécurisé c'est-à-dire que où on peut
rester vraiment tranquille et être sûr
que personne va toucher votre vie vous
faites partie des 11 millions
d'ukrainiens que la guerre a chassés de
chez eux une grande partie a été déplacé
au milieu au sein de l'ukraine est cinq
millions de personnes ont quitté le pays
vous vivez à kiev d'ordinaire si vous
êtes à paris en ce moment c'est parce
qu'il ya le salon du livre qu'elle vous
participez vous allez retourner en
ukraine à regret à quoi ressemble
précisément la vie quotidienne oui chez
nous
pour le moment dans nos crânes d'ouest
pas loin de la frontière et de hongrie
et de slovaquie
c'est presque tranquille il ya toujours
des sirènes
il faut toujours courir là l'abri des
bombes mais la région n'étaient pas
touchées par les bombardements parce que
peut-être à cause des proximité de la
frontière avec la hongrie parce que
messi sorbonne et grand ami dédé poutine
est peut être petit ne veut pas détruire
les villes habitées aussi par les
hongrois mais il ya trop des réfugiés
bien sûr c'est la population des rouges
de démocratie vraie 2,3 fois plus grand
que après avant de la guerre est comme
ça tous les écoles tous les
bâtiments administratifs
beaucoup d autres hôtels et touristique
sera occupé par les réfugiés et il ya
moins d des voitures et des gens qui
quittent pour les trajets maintenant a
fait il ya des des gens qui reviennent
chez eux il y a trente quarante mille
habitants décrivent qui revient chaque
jour à kyiv mais c'est pas sûr c'est pas
trés en fait
agréable pour le moment où placez-vous
il n'est pas question de retourner à
kiev non mais pas à cause de la sécurité
parce que si on est actif c'est pas
possible de voyager à l'étranger il n'ya
pas d'avion il n'y a pas de possibilité
de traverser la frontière comme ça on
reste un peu quand vous vous retournez
quand vous pensez à ce que vous avez
vécu vous et tous les ukrainiens depuis
deux mois qu'elle est là la première
image qui vous vient à l'esprit mon
premier sentiment or pour être scellé
que des réfugiés à la frontière parce
que les gens devaient attendre cinq six
jours pour traverser les frontières
et je me souviens parce que la première
fois j'ai traversé la frontière pour
revenir bien sûr mais je te donne le
quai le cul et avant il y avait un
minibus pas pour les passagers mais
complet avec 15 bébés
des enfants des brillantes qui étaient
détruits c'est une village près de kyiv
et c'était très froid parce que j'étais
là pendant la nuit et j'avais peur pour
ses petites soeurs d'enfants qui restait
qu'il devait rester quelques jours dans
le minibus sans fenêtre sans chauffage
je voudrais qu'on commente ensemble une
photo que vous avez posté sur twitter il
y a quelques jours quelques semaines
c'est la librairie de czerny ftja nice
tome au nord de kiev elle a été détruite
par un bombardement russe vous dites
vous avez rappelé à ce moment là qu'elle
a survécu cette librairie à deux guerres
mondiales mais pas à cette bon donc
russe
parce que la guerre de vladimir poutine
allait contre la culture ukrainienne je
suis sûr oui parce qu'il ya des théâtres
détruite il ya des musées détruite il ya
des directeurs des musées kidnappait
odete new et bien sûr je crois tous les
intellectuels de creil saut en longueur
parce que ils sont pros craignant pro
occidental est comme ça il est laissé en
fait montré que les ukrainiens sont les
mêmes gens que les russes ils n'ont pas
besoin de sa culture propre c'est la
culture qui fait les nations différentes
vous arrivez à écrire en ce moment ce
qui va pas la fiction non fiction oui
j'écris beaucoup d articles pour la
presse internationale j'ai créé mon
journal je veux préparer un livre sur
cette guerre
peut-être pour l'hiver prochain mais je
peux pas penser des romans parce que je
commençais à écrire un roman sur les
éléments à kiev à 1918 c'était la guerre
civile jusqu'à 1931 il ya beaucoup de
choses parler mais je peux pas continuer
avec le romande comme ça je je vais
revenir vraiment après la guerre
j'espère que ça va passer vite c'est pas
sûr parce que on voit qu est-ce qu il
passait peut-être savoir durer en fait
quelques mois votre dernier roman qui
s'appelle les abeilles grise se passe
dans le donbass on avait parlé ensemble
ici l'idée que la russie s'octroie
l'ensemble du dombass avec cette
offensive qui a commencé en début de
semaine comme elle l'a fait avec la
crimée par exemple est ce que cette idée
supportable pour les ukrainiens
aujourd'hui c'est pas supportable c'est
pas acceptable et en fait les ukraniens
sombrait des résisté jusqu'à la fin
parce que soit le cren reste indépendant
soit le crès n'existera pas il n'y aura
pas d'ukraine aujourd'hui possiblement
sans le donbass oui oui oui parce que
poutine ne va pas s'arrêter à de basses
il ne veut pas s'arrêter à odessa il
veut avait récupéré à annexer tout le
pays pour créer créer une union
soviétique à nouveau
autres photos que vous avez posté sur
twitter il y a quelques jours peut-être
vous allez vous nous dire où on est avec
un commentaire we love art comme nous
surmonterons nous reconstruirons c'est
comme ça que vous voyez les mois les
années à venir oui oui parce que
50% du pays est détruit on est où là
c'est irp et 7 ans de kyiv très spécial
très littéraire parce que là et ils
avaient beaucoup de villa qui
appartenait les écrivains soviétiques et
il ya aussi une grande résidence pour
les écrivains d'aujourd'hui la qui était
utilisée aussi papa au début pour
utilisé par les réfugiés des deux basses
et il y avait il avait et il y à
beaucoup d écrivains qui habitent là et
il y avait des traducteurs des écrivains
qui était-il aussi des professeurs des
universités la guerre a uni les
ukrainiens autour de cette idée de
résistance de résilience vous posez là
que vous posiez la question il ya
quelques jours dans un article à quoi
ressemblera la nation ukrainienne après
la guerre oui en fait c'est les trois
fois poutine à se
créer on peut dire récré et
renforce la nation ne craignent pas ce
que avec
l'ennemi comme la russie tous les
ukrainiens comprendre ok aussi il y à
aussi et des conflits à l'intérieur ils
sont trop petits si on les compare avec
l'existence du pays est comme ça il ya
tous les partis politiques sauf les gens
des parties prusse et ils sont ensemble
maintenant pour résister résister
c'était agression russe comment est ce
que vous comprenez l'héroïsation du
président ukrainien volodimir zelensky
ici en europe de l'ouest et en partie en
france à l'ehess quel est selon vous
l'expression de l'impuissance des
européens de l'ouest
oui c'est un phénomène très intéressant
je suis surpris par le courage des
présidents violence qui j'étais je n'ai
pas voté pour elle en ski mais je crois
il fait un bon boulot pour le moment
comme le président dans la situation
comme ça mais je ne suis pas prêt de
faire en icône du président parce que
c'est là c'est l'obligation de se
comporter comme ça pendant la guerre
pour chaque président de chaque pays
est-ce que vous en voulez aux européens
de l'ouest de marché sur cette ligne de
crête d'apporter une aide d'apporter du
soutien mais de ne pas intervenir plus
directement
j'ai besoin d'être militaire bien sûr
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de doute
il faut demander plus parce que vraiment
je crois aussi que l'europe ne veut pas
avoir la russie comme voisin en place
des ducs rennes et bien sûr beaucoup des
politiciennes européens sont un peu
passif et ils ont peur d'un péché
poutine d'empêcher la russie mais je
crois c'est la politique correcte pour
chaque jour répétait la même chose
jusqu'à le moment là la guerre est finie
on vous le souhaite le retour des jours
heureux et deux jours de paix en tout
cas merci beaucoup c'est un drake
kourkov d'être venu ce matin à nouveau
sur le plateau de parer direct bon
retour à vous en ukraine et bon séjour
ici appareils à très bientôt mais on se
retrouve juste après la pause avec
sandrine gomez
[Musique]